bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
tous en piste pour l'emploi c'est le
défi de saint quentin en yvelines
dans ce numéro nous découvrirons quels
sont les secteurs et les entreprises qui
recrutent ainsi que leurs partenaires et
le grand rendez vous à ne pas manquer
alors où on l emploi à saint quentin en
yvelines
on vous explique tout c'est parti
[Musique]
et
lisez sur les entreprises pour relancer
l'emploi
c'est le pari de saint quentin en
yvelines qui pilote depuis plus de 20
ans la semaine de l'emploi
cette année une nouveauté tout en un
seul jour le 29 mars le vélodrome
accueillera des centaines d'entreprises
du territoire des écoles des organismes
de formation et le pôle emploi
au programme job dating atelier
recrutement réseautage et démonstration
est l'occasion de découvrir de nouveaux
métiers et de répondre aux besoins des
secteurs en tension
un emploi c'est d'avoir être connue des
sociétés vous allez mieux que vous ce ne
sont reconnus vous avez un pouvoir
d'achat plus important c'est un lieu
d'échangés le monde du travail
c'est dans les changes constants ici
vous vous améliorez vous apprenez des
choses nouvelles
nous avons des besoins dans différents
domaines
tout ce qu'il ya à génieau riz
une forte demande services à la personne
d'une forte demande chef de projet d'une
forte demande les secteurs de la
logistique au nautic évidemment voilà
donc nous avons une particularité terre
d'innovation niveau de saint quentin en
yvelines qui s'associent effectivement
avec les entreprises qui sont dédiés
dans ce secteur et un besoin récurrent
en termes d'ingénieurs des sous types de
postes et l'agglomération souhaite
secondes et les entreprises en recherche
de compétences pour cela elle prend les
devants on a su jusqu'à fin décembre
2010 est qu'il y avait un manque à peu
près 5000 postes dans le numérique
lorsque nous l'avons su dans l'espèce de
tout de suite on a mis en action un
certain nombre de choses et on a créé
l'école numérique avec une labellisation
du coup on a créé une activité sans
passer par d'autres systèmes pour capter
des centres de formation au sein de de
50 ans à divine afin qu' il ya un
parcours rapide de formation soient
dédiés pour les entreprises ont donc
bien entendu aujourd'hui c'est
fondamental que vous sachiez utiliser
les outils parce que vous devez
multiplier votre votre résultat votre
production votre créativité et cette
journée aussi montre d'abord les les
écoles que nous avons créée à saint
quentin pour inciter les gens à
s'inscrire et à augmenter leurs cultures
numériques pour mieux réussir dans leur
emploi
le rendez vous du 29 mars permettra aux
entreprises de rencontrer les demandeurs
d'emploi et les futurs talents
l'occasion pour elle de se faire
connaître et d'exposer dans métiers en
tension elles recrutent
nous les avons rencontrés on cherche
aujourd'hui à aller vers le véhicule
autonome qui pour nous commence par être
en véhicules électriques
c'est plus facile qu'un petit bras qui
viennent recharger et remplir le
réservoir et le véhicule connecté
repérer les itinéraires et dangers
éventuels détecter les piétons réguler
la vitesse mais aussi prendre aux soins
du passager conducteurs en vérifiant ses
battements de coeur et si besoin le
transporter à l'hôpital
c'est le véhicule autonome agora pulse
développé par segula technologies
présente dans 28 pays l'entreprise
trappistes accompagne les grands acteurs
de l'industrie dans les domaines de
l'automobile l'aéronautique le
ferroviaire et le naval nous recrutons
dont tous types de profils techniques
sur les métiers de l'automobile donc des
ingénieurs et des techniciens et nous
recherchons plus particulièrement donc
des ingénieurs des techniciens mécanique
des concepteurs câblage d ingénieur
électronique
aujourd'hui nous utilisons tous les
canaux de recrutement puisque le marché
de l'automobile est un marché ultra
concurrentiel et un marché très
dynamique
nous sommes très présents sur les
réseaux sociaux et nous sommes également
très présent auprès des étudiants nous
avons des relations privilégiées avec
l'estac à l'estaca située à montigny le
bretonneux accueil 2050 étudiants de
futurs ingénieurs dans les domaines de
l'automobile de l'aéronautique du
spatial et des transports guidés le
partenaire idéal pour les entreprises
chaque année segula technologies propose
200 offres de stages les recrues oeuvre
dans divers domaines à la pointe de la
technologie
véhicule autonome la réalité augmentée
est l'impression 3d et ses stages vont
nous permettre de pouvoir découvrir ses
étudiants tout comme ils vont découvrir
l'entreprise pour pouvoir à l'issue de
la période de stage leur proposer un
emploi au sein du groupe segula mais
elle lui a saisi la balle au bond
j'avais choisi la spécialisation
automobile est particulièrement
l'engagement véhicule donc c'est là où
ce à travers des coûts des matériaux
j'étais à l'estaca je connaissais déjà
séduit là parce qu'elles étaient
présents dans notre école
donc il bel effort en entreprise quand
même temps ils travailler avec les
associations jeu c'est vrai que l'être
implémenter à 50 ans l'élite ça aide
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'entreprises qui
sont autour de notre école pour cela
nous permet de développer des bonnes
relations avec les entreprises iront à
elancourt nous nous rendons à crm à un
autre partenaire des grandes écoles de
l'agglomération
nous avons un certain nombre de
stagiaires qui viennent de l'estaca qui
font soit leur stage deux dernières
années quatrième ou cinquième année soit
on en a aussi un certain nombre en
première année qui font leur stage
donc ouvriers à serena nous avons
également un certain nombre de
stagiaires qui viennent de l'ubs est est
ce qu est que nous accueillons à crm à
tous les angles filiale d'air france
spécialisée dans la remise à neuf de
pièces de moteurs et d'équipements
aéronautiques
l'entreprise recrute crm à c'est un seul
site basé à elancourt
nous sommes aujourd'hui environ 385
personnes qui concentre à la fois les
métiers de production et des métiers et
tous et toutes les autres fonctions
support c'est à dire des ajusteurs
ajusteur monteur tourneur fraiseur
chaudronnier contrôleurs des opérateurs
en projection thermique les aussi des
ingénieurs pour la production ainsi que
du personnel rh qualité sécurité
environnement et marketing pour la
partie support nous avons créer 30
emplois entre 2015 et 2016 et dans les
trois ans à venir nous espérons recruter
et nous devons recruter 150 personnes en
production
on a de toute façon un parcours
d'intégration qui non seulement va leur
permettre d'acquérir des compétences
techniques n'ont peut-être pas encore
mais également toute la culture
aéronautique qualité exigés pour
postuler la motivation l'engagement la
rigueur et le respect de la qualité de
la sécurité bagage technique appréciée
autre partenaire d'airbus permaswage
implanté aux clayes-sous-bois depuis
l'entreprise possède plus de 75 % du
marché mondial dans son domaine celui
des raccords serti forte de 140 salariés
l'entreprise recrute elle aussi
magasinier opérateurs mécanique pour des
besoins ponctuels tourneur sur commande
numérique pour une collaboration plus
pérenne sur les détourneurs à commande
numérique
il ya une pénurie il ya beaucoup moins
d'écoles de moins en mois d'école qui
prépare moins en moins en moins
d'étudiants qui qui veulent rentrer dans
ces filières techniques beaucoup et on a
des difficultés parce qu'on peut trouver
aussi des candidats mais qui sont pas
forcément sérieux donc voilà trouver des
gens qui soient sérieux qui connaissent
le métier c'est de plus en plus
difficile là aussi la plupart des
métiers nécessitent une formation au
sein de l'entreprise
sur les quarante tourneur que compte
l'entreprise cinq sont actuellement en
apprentissage
qualités requises être méticuleux
sérieux et concentrés on se rend compte
quand même que les personnes qui veulent
travailler chez père m'a sauvé c'est des
gens qui habitent autour des gens vont
pas faire des kilomètres et des
kilomètres pour venir voir
donc c'est vrai que je privilégierai les
contacts locaux
[Musique]
les entreprises peuvent compter sur les
partenaires locaux pour les aider dans
leur recherche de la perle rare le pôle
emploi les centres de formation les
grandes écoles et la cité des métiers
rapproche entreprises et talents de
demain et pour trouver les candidats
idéaux
direction le pôle emploi de trappes
valérie touya échange régulièrement avec
les entreprises où nous avons des
entreprises là sur le secteur qui ont
des besoins en personnel avec des
compétences techniques pointues en
fonction des postes on propose aux
employeurs de les aider à former les
demandeurs d'emploi qui n'ont pas les
compétences initiales recherché sur tout
ce qui est industriel méconnaissance des
demandeurs d'emploi des possibilités
d'emploi et quand on passe une annonce
chaudronnier il ya des gens qui ont des
compétences qui pose viennent d'autres
métiers mais qui vont pas penser à
postuler sur l'offre de chaudronnier et
le dispositif pee de pôle emploi permet
de parfaire la formation du demandeur
d'emploi avant son intégration en
entreprise
d'autres choisissent la reconversion ce
matin sensibilisation à la comptabilité
d'entreprise dans les locaux de l'ifocop
montant de la réduction et vous avez
trop eh bien je vais vous reversez créé
en 1969 le centre de formation il faut
coop dispense des cours en alternance
pour les adultes
community manager contrôleur de gestion
concepteurs informatique commerce
hôtellerie
ici chacun acquièrent les compétences
qui lui manque
quatre mois en centre de formation et
quatre mois en entreprise
une équation qui permet d'être
rapidement opérationnel aujourd'hui il
est vrai que nous accueillons
essentiellement des demandeurs d'emploi
qui
ont subi un licenciement ou qu'ils ont
besoin d'une reconversion
professionnelle parce que dans leur
métier on va dire d'origine
ils sont ils ont besoin soit d'un
diplôme soit de compétences nouvelles
le cas de yann et de mouna j'ai choisi
la formation pour le titre de
responsable du hse donc qualité hygiène
sécurité environnement
j'ai choisi leaf au club de saint
quentin en yvelines parce que le cadre
me semblait beaucoup plus agréable et le
bassin d'entreprises aussi qui est ici
est extrêmement bénéfique
je suis en formation à l'ifocop en
formation contrôleur de gestion
c'est une formation concrète
opérationnelle qui permet aujourd'hui
d'accéder au marché d'emploi de par son
modèle basé sur l'alternance un modèle
de formation qui a prouvé son efficacité
ce qui est assez caractéristique c'est
que à l'issue de la formation
le taux de retour à l'emploi de nos
stagiaires il faut coop est de 80 % en
moyenne
il a même atteint 90 % sur l'année 2016
donc effectivement on peut dire que la
formation est un véritable levier un
véritable tremplin pour le retour à
l'emploi et à peine entrés en formation
de gestionnaire de paie les stagiaires
sont déjà sollicités par les entreprises
pour leur période d'application pratique
qui débouche dans plus de 80 % d'écart
par une embauche
pour ceux qui se cherchent encore
direction de la cité des métiers conseil
information et orientation pour un
public très large
collégiens lycéens et étudiants pour
l'orientation et les adultes qui
souhaitent se reconvertir se former tout
au long de leur vie professionnelle ou
créer leur entreprise et demandeurs
d'emploi
ils sont aussi accompagnés dans leurs
recherches à la cité des métiers ce
qu'on a mis en place ce sont des
ateliers et un pôle conseil pour aider
toutes les personnes qui envisagent
éventuellement de créer leur activité
pour aider ces personnes là à réfléchir
à leur dimension entrepreneuriale c'est
à dire qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
d'être de créer son activité d'être
entrepreneur vraiment en amont de tout
accompagnement au projet
la reconversion professionnelle est le
projet le plus récurrent différents
dispositifs sont suggérées bilan de
compétences validation des acquis et
dispositif d' aide à la formation
ce jour-là un forum des métiers en
uniforme est organisé tous les métiers
de la sécurité recrute gendarmes
pompiers gardiens de prison certains
étaient venus quérir informations et
conseils avant de sauter le pas et le 29
mars ils seront tous au vélodrome c'est
très important pour nous d'être présent
sur ce type d'événement locales pour
nous faire connaître
parce que parfois on connaît pas les
entreprises qui sont juste à côté de
chez nous et pour nous c'est important
effectivement de pouvoir recruter aussi
dans un bassin à proximité de
l'entreprise déjà primo parce que moi
j'ai besoin d'eux
j'ai des recrutements à faire pour aussi
que l'événement soit comment dire une
réussite pour l'agglomération
on a des conseillers qui seront présents
toute la journée qu'ils des conseillers
qui seront là aussi pour présenter
l'offre de services numériques
et puis des conseillers qui sont là pour
aider à la préparation des candidats
il faut coptes sont pas effectivement
présentes
nous avons été labellisée école
numérique depuis janvier 2018 pour les
formations de community manager et de
développeur intégrateur web et à ce
titre sur le forum il y aura un espace
réservé pour les écoles labellisées
une fois les cours terminés jumet
rentrée pourquoi pas parce que là il
faut vraiment mettre toutes les chances
de leur côté pour la recherche de stage
un dernier conseil pour mettre toutes
les chances de votre côté
renseignez vous bien sûr l'entreprise et
le secteur d'activité que vous ciblez
montrez-vous motivés intéressés et
sérieux rendez vous le 29 mars au
vélodrome
ciao